25 years ago that was for sale
evident that to remain true to the
fellows of European humanism a nexus
Institute had to be founded on the
educational ideas of the novel in which
had found its supreme expression the
magic mountain of talisman practice the
art of conversations listening to
different sometimes complete opposing
views as no one in advance can claim to
be in the position of the truth keep
alive a book culture and idea of
classics cultivate the cosmopolitan
spirit of humanism as a counterpoint to
both ignorance and fanaticism so when we
started to think about how to celebrate
our 25th anniversary that was perfectly
clear that it had to be a symposium
about the meaning of all that the magic
mountain represents for our time and
when you came into this whole when you
were not too late you could listen to
the prelude to the first act of actors
Logan green which was not only mom's
favorite opera but also the opera that
starts with a duo and a Magic Mountain
sent us about a duel between two
competing worldviews fighting for the
soul of Europe and with that same duel
we will start today's Nexus symposium
and I'm delighted that two brave
philosophers accepted our invitation to
discuss the premises and consequences of
each other complete opposite and
competing worldviews and I'll call them
brave because it has become extremely
rare the two philosophically opponents
really meet eye to eye now issue those
who have read the novel you know that at
the very end of the novel in deities a
physical duel
Natha is challenging certain beany it's
a shooting said when he refuses to shoot
and then after kills himself that
fortunately will not happen today I
double-checked they don't have a gun
they even do not have a fake gun
which they will have hidden Amsterdam no
Fagan's so welcome everybody at today's
meeting Mountain and please do give a
very warm welcome to learn after also
known as Alex on the Dugan and Ludo
Foucault set a blini also know as burner
Hardy leafy thank you so first of all I
always prefer the battle of ideas so the
physical war and I am very very happy
that we could exchange was mister the
not only we who is famous on the world
scale not in the physical do health
because sometimes were in the same
frontline normally on different sides in
the physical battle so I prefer to speak
and to exchange their idea here not in
the physical battle maybe it is the one
way to avoid that or at least to try
first of all I would like to say that
now president macron recently a sad that
the hegemony of the West is over the
same thing about liberalism of global
liberalism has said our president mr.
Putin there was recently issue of
Foreign Affairs miss Varens Acharya
article dedicated to the decline of
Western power and I think that it is
something where I'm going to discuss in
my eyes it is almost obvious that there
is such decline in your book Empire five
kings you have noticed very interesting
thing evaporating of American presence
in the Middle East and the guise of
Kurds I think that we are approaching
there and not of to the end of the
history as as mr. Fujiyama has said but
the end of political modernity
and that is the end of something very
very important that we should think and
that the end of Western hegemony of
American dominance or globalism global
liberalism it is something historical in
itself is not technical I interpret that
as for example in niche words so in the
beginning of the modernity the humans
have killed the gods in order to
liberate but that was suicide
killing the gods we have killed
ourselves and now welcome to the last
stage of nihilism and editors think in
your book you define mystery American
Empire of global global liberal system
as the system of nihilism based on
nothing it's very interesting idea and I
would like to ask you why you still
defend this more and more open nihilist
system why you fight for this decaying
declining modernity and why you invest
all your intellectual power in order to
defend that of course I'm certainly not
fighting for nihilism I'm fighting on
the contrary to combat nihilism I'm
fighting for political modernity because
in my world it means democracy freedom
equality between women and men
secularism and so on political modernity
which is probably in crisis I refuse the
idea of its decline and of his
disappearance because I strongly believe
that it is a plus for the world
and about nihilism I read you - since
long
you are my adversary we think oppositely
on many fields but I recognize your
importance especially on the Russian
scene and for me that's why I read you
carefully for me the embodiment of need
ISM today is you and your friends and
the Eurasian current and this must be
the atmosphere which fills your books
and the way in which you dissolve the
very idea of human rights of personal
freedoms of singularities in some big
blocks of community big faiths sacred
origins of all so on there is a perfume
of nihilism that really embarrasses me
when I read your revolution
conservatories your and all your works
about your rages in the beginning of the
90 so what the interesting
if you make a kind of identity between
nihilism and refuse to the Western
interpretation of human rights freedom
and democracy liberal democracy so in
that sense I agree I am against that
because for me it is not universe they
are not universal values first of all I
think the democracy the content of
democracy is changing I have spoken once
miss Fukuyama and Fukuyama the the
defiant the modern understanding of
liberal democracy as the rule of the
minorities against the majority because
majority can always transform in the
populism and fascism or communist so
that is completely new idea I think and
I think that if I don't share this new
understanding of liberal democracy or if
for example I challenge that the subject
of the freedom should be individual and
that is the essence the axis of human
rights ideology if I consider the
identity of the man of human culture of
society not to be reducible to
individuality so for example in our
Russian tradition the subject of freedom
or the subject human subject is not in
the video it is collective and that was
in in the time of Tsar's that was
defined by church after that by
communists but always collective
identity was dominant in our culture as
well as in China in his culture in
Indian culture are up to the same level
in the Islamic culture but I think that
I am Nikhil nihilist in the sense that I
refuse universality of the modern
Western value I don't think they are
universal I think that Western they are
modern I think the West is very powerful
still in order to defend then
but I just challenge that that is the
only way to interpret democracy as the
rule of minorities against majority the
only way to interpret the freedom as
individual freedom only way to interpret
human rights projecting Western modern
the ballistic version of human on the
other culture that's my opinion you know
your tradition the Russian tradition
better than me but I'm enough a friend
of Russia to know that what you said
about the place of subjectivity in
Russian tradition is not true you have
also a tradition of X n of Pushkin of
Turin EF a part of cycle of all the
glorious tradition of the dissidents who
fought the totally terrorism of the
Soviet Union who fought in the name of
individuality rights of the subjects and
human rights and this element you cannot
say that it is not part of the Russian
tradition and again you know I devoted
such a big part of my life to defend
Russia against slavery totally terrorism
and so on to be authorized to say that
democracy Fukuyama I was not here during
the debate with Fukuyama but I suppose
what I would say at least myself if that
democracy is a complex concept and a
complex process it will the rule of the
majority and the rule of the mayor of
the minority also and the rule of
Parliament it is a very complex
architecture which involves which which
which knows evolutions throughout time
which enriches itself and the difference
between democracy and all sorts of
authority' ism
including the one of Putin in Russia
today if that democracy is always open
and always open to change always open to
progress always open to enrichment all
we drawls all of that and about nihilism
let's agree on one point
you speak of need who did not say that
men killed the gods by the way but God
which is a very different thing but the
best definition of kneel ISM for me we
know it we have it in our memory a
russia with his 24 millions of death
during the Great Patriotic War earth in
Europe occupied by the Naziism the Jews
my people nearly exterminated
there is one definition of kneel ISM
which is those who committed these
crimes which means the Nazis and when it
is means they did not came from the sky
from the sky of Chile or of Tibet they
came from ideologists from cow meat from
from Spangler from Stuart from Berlin
from Karl house however all people which
I am sorry to know to see that you like
and you quote and you inspire yourself
of their works so for me when I say that
you are journalists when I say that
Putin is analyst when I said that there
is Moscow a morbid atmosphere of kneel
ISM which creates by the way from real
dad's an operative skya
mr. nem self and and so many others
killed in Moscow or in London every day
I mean it and I mean that alas for this
great Russian civilization today there
is a bad dark wind of near ISM in its
proper sense which is a Nazi and fascist
sense which is blowing on this great
Russia I agree I think that's phenomenon
of fascism and National Socialism it I
agree it isn't nihilism I agree and I
don't defend that because it is modern
phenomenon in my eyes all modernity is
purely nihilist
in liberalism is Nahas communism as
nihilism and fascism as well and I think
that I agree with you about the crimes
committed by Hitler because my people as
well suffered a lot we have lost many
many millions of the people killed
because they were Slavs as exactly on
the same scale as they were Jews and our
people Soviet people Russian people fold
this patriotic war in order to stop the
fascism in Europe in Russia and as well
to save all the peoples suffered
suffering in that situation and I
strongly blame the all kind of racism so
if I find something interesting
interesting in Heidegger in Schmitt and
a conservative revolution in Germany it
is the points of some political realism
on some geopolitical thought on some
traditionalism and the criticism of
modernity that was proper to this
conservative movement but not the racist
I always in all my books I always stress
and I am bold enough if I vote fascist
or racism to recognize that I
I'm making many many bold statement I am
blamed for them I am against liberalism
against individualism against human
rights as ideology but I am against
racism too and that is clear I don't I
don't defend that but I don't think that
racism I blame because it is anglo-saxon
liberal construction based on the
hierarchy between the people I think
this criminal and I think that the same
crime now the globalist repeats because
the what global is the Liberals as
yourself and people who support your
ideas now try to affirm as universal
values simply modern Western liberal
values and that is a kind of new kind of
racism cultural civilization racism you
say you are for everybody who accepts
open society they are good guys all who
challenge the open society they are as
popper and sub title of his book says
they are enemies of open society so
there's a new manic and division that
new racism who is in favor of Western
values they are good everybody who
challenged that in Islamic traditional
Russian traditional Chinese tradition in
India tradition in everywhere they are
populist and they are classified as
fascism I think that is new new racism
oh my dear there is really three real
real points of disagreement first of all
I'm sorry but when you speak of
globalization you have a short idea of
it globalization does not mean there is
a bad globalization of course which
means uniformization of the world but
globalization has a lot of Western
thinkers conceive it lie as I conceive
it like many people here in Amsterdam
conservative means not a uniformity
means
an openness to the other means some
bridges between civilization means some
nexus between cultures means some
importation expectation of worlds
theorems and so this is what
globalization can mean to and believe me
we are very numerous in the West to
battle for that number two when you say
that that to believe in universal values
is a new form of totally Teresa man sir
I'm sorry but this is so short the real
point is that in every civilization
there are some great things which have
been invented your civilization the
Russian one which is a proper
civilization great which our River and
respects invented for example through
Alexander Solzhenitsyn one of my
Master's invented the very idea of the
fight against totally tourism it's huge
what Sorensen did and nobody will steal
that hugeness from Russian culture so
many Western thinkers tried to think
freedom against totally terrorism what
it is what is a camp and so on it
belongs to a Russian man to have
produced this masterpiece which was the
FT Perico girl in a gulag nothing nobody
will take that from Russians version on
the same sense Europe invented a few
things also which are gains for Humanity
for example equal rights between women
and
for example the right for a body not to
be tortured not to be Unchained or
enslaved this right has been invented
has been produced by a philosophy which
has been called philosophy of
enlightenment and which birthplace was
Europe so the idea is not to impose a
pattern on another one it is to take in
every civilization the good for the rest
of humanity that it invented and about
I'm happy to hear that you don't like
racism but I'm not so sure that you are
sincere
I read few days ago a book of hew called
la revolution conservatories in French
page 256 and 56 where you spoke about
Jews I'm not only concerned about Jews
I'm concerned about all but this one
word about Jews and about the
metaphysical rivalry and war between
Aryans area and Jews and you said that
this was a challenge that this was a
debate of the knot of the century but of
the time this is anti-semitism and I'm
not surprised because all the men which
you quoted and from which you draw your
inspiration Spangler Heidegger who is
also a great philosopher of course and
others they're contaminated corrupted
infected by this plague which is
anti-semitism and alas you too and in
you in your debates
with Allender boudoir in france with
your connections with alain soral who
preface one of your books and with one
of the alas of the leaders of the french
anti-semitism all of these were spirals
so how can you say that racism is
foreign to you
so absolutely foreign to me i as well i
think that i believe that people have
their angels their people have their
archetypes so the peoples are not only
collective of bodies of physical
presence but the people have soul and
there is the soul of jewish people that
I admire that I respect I have many
friends in the between Israel in
traditionalist circles of Israel that
share my opinion they are Jews believe
who believe in God Judah and that is in
confrontation with you you have they
define yourself as Jew not believing in
a Jewish God for them for my friends it
would be absolutely anti-semitic
affirmation because the Jews are the
people of God and that is the essence so
without God the Jews lose their essence
religious mission that place in the
history but that is important that there
are difference between the people and
I'm insisting on the difference between
the souls of the people between the
angels of the people but I am against
any kind of hierarchy or racism I don't
say that the in European or Greek or
European cell German Indian Iranian
civilization are better or tradition
better genes a Semitic or Islamic or
Judaic I think they are different and
concerning the globalization process you
have described if it would be so as you
have said we would have nothing against
that if that is dialogue when everybody
participates Christian Muslim Chinese
defending their set of values if
globalization will be the open and just
and really democratic dialogue in order
to find the better in all the
civilization nobody would oppose to it I
think at least myself I wouldn't oppose
but now it is the Western projection of
what Wester things is good or bad as
universal value' capitalism market
market economy human rights ideology
individual freedom had an ism
technocracy
all these elements of Western historical
experience social experience are
projected on the world scale and that is
called universal so the West is called
universal I am against that and
concerning Solzhenitsyn I am I for I
follow him as well because he was lava
file and he fought against communist
totalitarianism precisely in favor of
Russian people as collective identity
Solzhenitsyn Solzhenitsyn I am against
Soviet totalitarianism I am not in favor
I'm not defending communism I was
dissident and 80s but I'm not pro
liberal dissident a soldier needs an S
Solzhenitsyn I am anti-liberal
he was very critical and a liberal
dissident so I think
Herzl you have mentioned you have
mentioned some name in Russian history
mostly or most of them were Westerners
so they could ever ethnically or
culturally Russian but ideological they
were not Russian day they didn't follow
our tradition and our tradition was
based on completely different
anthropology and ontology and heard some
interesting
he was Westerner in the
use and emigration but he returned after
to the very nationalist position so many
Turgenev not but hurtin yes interesting
so one of the the the leader of the
Russian Westerners
I mean experienced the West the Western
culture in emigration returned as many
our dissidents from the returning from
the West with very national nationalist
ideas so I think we we should carefully
carefully conserve this identity Jewish
Semitic Islamic Russian European in
different forms and try to find the
nexus between them so avoiding this
simplistic version totally terrorism
against democracy Hannah Arendt that I
admire as well said that totalitarianism
is modern phenomenon it is not
traditional phenomenon so if we ever
measure everything democracy liberalism
or fascism or all common comments
totalitarian it's simplistic version I
think now we need to talk to imagine
something else something beyond the
modernity and in that sense all three
political theory liberalism communism
and fascism
they are the ideology to overcome to get
beyond them to the and but as well there
are something interesting in in some
communist thinker as grunt she for
example or some called French Communist
as a tie or the bore or leftist you have
from the left there are so many
interesting thinkers we could not make
identification for example but I with
good luck we could not say the Heidegger
is the same as as vensim or all liberals
are Hiroshima bombing criminals so we
need to find something sane or try to
satisfied something saying but in order
to overcome
about Judaism you have to revise a
little your information Judaism and God
is a little more complicated like that
than that to be a Jew of course it is to
have a relationship with God but it's a
relationship which is based on study
more than in Creed and that is one of
the main difference between Judaism and
Christianity but no no problem about
Excel what you don't seem to understand
and what did agree what was the
greatness of Arizona was the ability to
go back and forth to enrich the Western
tradition with the Russian tradition and
vice versa
this was the greatness of a zone of push
king of all the anti Eurasian the
pro-european Russians of the 19th and of
the 20th century Sakharov for example
whom I who is for me another great
heroes of the 20th century he was he had
a foot in Russia and he had to hear the
foot in liberalism and democracy he
believed in the two and he devoted all
his life in the task of combining the
two and what I fear when I read you and
what I find when I read you and all not
only you all the the writers of this
Eurasian current which is supposed to
inspire of Putin and what I what I find
so morbid
so smelling death and so nihilistic is
the fact of conceiving these
civilizations as blocks of course your
respect I know your respect Islam
you respect Japanese civilization you
respect
Turkish severe civilization and maybe
the Jews but ok but on two conditions
that everyone remains at his place and
that there is as little communication
between all of them and this conception
of culture of civilizations considered
as blocks which are closed on themselves
you share it with an American Thinker
whom you know and you should have quoted
him more than readable it is samuel
huntington samuel huntington with his
idea of clash of civilizations is
matching with the thinkers which you
represent today in russia with this idea
of blocks closed and virtually at war
against each other and when you look at
the DB put in today when you look at
what he is saying when he addresses
europe when he addresses america when he
addresses human rights and so on it is
when he addresses ukraine when he
aggresses ukraine in crimea it is a
discourse of war so a philosophy of war
civilizations conceived as holistic
blocks has as a natural outcome a
practice of war which is implemented by
vladimir putin today and I really
believe that between you Huntington way
of thinking and the occupation of Crimea
the 13,000 deaths in Ukraine the war in
Syria
with this bloodbath tragic and horrible
through the link between the two I agree
I agree I appreciate very much
Huntington I think his his vision is
much more correct than Fukuyama or
liberalism that civilization exists and
after the fall of this to ideological
camp
communism against capitalism the
civilization will play a decisive role
and the history I don't think in
Huntington I agree as well there is a
kind of simplistic version of
civilization I have dedicated my last 24
books to the study of civilizations
trying to find the differences inside of
them so trying to to describe them in
the complete Francis and speaking about
bridges differences we all know but did
you devote as many books to find some
bridges some connections difference I
know breezers yes yes interesting so
when we try for sure when we try when we
try to exchange the two Toto build the
bridges too early
without knowing the structure of the
other the problem is the other but the
West don't understand the other as
something positive is all the same and
we immediately try to find the bridges
there are illusions and not the bridges
because we are projecting ourselves it
is the same ideology of the same
darkness we need first to understand 24
books dedicated to understand the other
than ourselves that the west then
Islamic Jewish European Russian thought
considered to do something that is known
I think that civilizations are unknown
unknown actors they are only the
emerging now and we need to study them
first correctly and after that to create
the bridges do you come often to America
do you come often to United States from
time to time now i'm sanctions but under
sanctions but ok
we'll be allowed to go back you you
would discover in the American
universities
nothing is more active than these
departments of studies of the Otterness
this is one by the way America's a lot
of defects a lot of problem but one of
the greatness of America today and since
long but today more than ever is this
attention to the adonis is this very
insightful look in the in the body and
in the south of all foreign cultures you
cannot imagine how vivid vibrant open to
the other of the American universities
and sometimes also the French
universities so knowledge of the other
Ness we have in the West
unfortunately opening our arms our
hearts and you arms and you heart to the
other honest not enough now you said I'm
right okay one question what do you
think about the aggression of your
country me when France aggressed Algeria
when I was a boy I was 14 years old I
was in the streets when America agrees
Vietnam I was demonstrating today what
do you think of the occupation of Crimea
and what do you think of the aggression
of eastern Ukraine by paramilitaries or
militaries of your country you and your
book you say you deplore that you
manifested it against Americans so you
can we can change our minds so you now
you defending the American Empire the
world liberal Empire and that is your
option or your choice that I respect I
think that I offend Eurasian
civilization
as not as the country I'm not too much
what rate of the Russian Federation and
all our government does
I'm not automatically support all that I
have critical Crimea Crimea I'm coming
I'm approaching so in my opinion there
at Ukraine is the country with two
people and two civilization ethnical are
very very close because it is not
Ukrainian people there Ukraine and it is
the part of the cradle of Russian
civilization in some way Ukrainians are
more direct parents of us that they are
pure Russians they are more pure
Russians than ourselves because they
live still in the cradle of our
tradition and we migrated to the East so
the historical a Ukraine was created by
two tendency of aggression of a Russian
Empire aggression against Turkey
because the new Russia novorossiya was
the part of turkish territories in
Crimea and eastern modern days Ukraine
and the other part was taken from Poland
and that was the that wasn't liberated
or created by Western Russian so-called
Ukrainians so Russia have has
historically during aggression against
neighbor country countries created
Ukraine and the last piece of it was
added by Stalin from austro-hungarian
the Lamberg a lone wolf district so that
was composed entity that appeared after
the fall of the Soviet Union and there
was the chance to create Ukrainian
identity as for example there were there
is Belgium identity with two people
living considering respecting each other
so there are two people
if for example the valence would like to
say that Flemish there a second second
type of the human a subhuman because
they're German for example a Protestants
that was exactly the same that happened
to the Ukraine the the state that you
Lee born state that didn't exist in the
history had the chance to create its
national idea national structure
respecting both people living there in
eastern Ukraine and the Western Ukraine
and to find a balance and I supported
that and I have the partisans including
in the western Ukraine at sharing this
view but finally politically that was
only the part western part that in my
done whether you were trying to inspire
them to to get off from our so-called
Russia and that in that part western
part has submitted the other a Russia
intervened in order to save this part of
Ukraine and after we have committed the
error I think we should liberate the
eastern Ukraine which Crimea and to
propose to recreate Ukraine independent
Ukraine as the bridge between US and
Europe and basing on the respect of both
our identities and that was the mistake
that way we have taken only Crimea our
own leaden bus it was mistake we should
restore a reconstruct Ukraine when
Yanukovych was for the moment the only
bridge which exists which has been
created is between Crimea and Russia for
the moment the only building which has
been done is a huge military bases in
Sebastopol of Russia directed against
enemies I suppose and I don't see in the
last year's in the speeches of Putin or
others in a tendency to rebuild a
bi-national great Ukraine I
he pure and rabbit rabbit aggression and
violation of the international law I see
an attempt of rewriting and of revising
history that by the way if I understood
you well you are talking today when you
say that Ukraine is a new state this is
what I heard in how can you say that
Ukraine that the point of history
existed before Russia okay okay of that
sense
okay the Mosel 99 century before year
1000 that was the common history of the
voice of the Princeville OD me who was
paralyzed and who is at the origin of
the Christianization era of modern
ukraine a village in russia was a prince
of kiev not of miskova so ukraine is an
old country more ancient than Russia
okay so every country's are new so the
best we can do mr. Dougan the best we
can do is to respect as imperfect as
they are the international laws the laws
that might prevent us to fall in another
catastrophe like the one who custard you
people 24 25 million brave soldiers and
civilians destroyed by Hitler and who
costed Europe such a ruin there is an
architecture of security an architecture
of security which has been built after
the Cold War in cooperation by the way
between the west and Russia had many
steps and we have to do our best for our
children
I don't know if you have children as
okay Roger grandchildren okay for them
we have to do our best to preserve and
to save the
earn perfect but this is even crucial
architecture of security and what Putin
did in Crimea what he is doing a
determinate in eastern Ukraine what he's
doing when he plays with fire and with
my second bloodbath in Syria goes
against the interests of our children
and grandchildren I don't think I agree
on the principle that we need some
international law but law reflects the
status quo the balance of power the law
could not be absolutely abstract for
example the law is established after the
victory when the west and the Soviet
Union were together we have won over
Hitler we established our international
law when the communism Falls and the
Soviet Union were collapsed their walls
attempt to create the Western center
flow based on the victory in the Cold
War and that law now the International
balance of power is in decay we are
challenging it and we try to create new
markets international architecture that
would respect civilizations so I think
we are coming to the end of the multiple
unipolar world system that structure
based on this ideological
and geopolitical victory or because the
end of the unipolar moment as Charles
Krauthammer has said now we have it it
is now so psychology civilizations
reappear and we could not put these
emergence of civilizations in the old
version of Westphalia national state
system today we need to revise that in
multipolar way in order to respect the
other accept it not only culturally I
agree with you about American
universities because I'm admirer of boas
tradition
anthropology on his all his line France
boss and Claude lévi-strauss they are
for me they are masters I am following
their they my teachers this anthropology
of anthropological pluralism I agreed
that is precisely American and French
tradition but it is not reflected in the
politics or reflected in the very very
perverted way so I think there is big
contradiction between the this
anthropological thought and American
Universities on French University and
kind of a very aggressive colonial and
new imperialist form to promote American
interest on the world scale with the
weapon I could not blame only Putin for
Syria for example you were active as
well in the Libyan crisis that costed
total the Libyan people so there the
rivers of blood so you should suggested
to our overthrow assets and that was
support of the part in this civil word
against the other so I think that we
could not accuse in that situation only
Putin it is perverted image Putin
reacted put it put in tries to affirm
Russian voice and Chinese voice as well
in this situation that is 5 King against
against Empire you are on the side of of
Empire so you are accused on all the
crimes the 5 King we are five Kings I am
I am on the side of Solzhenitsyn I am of
the c100 love of I am of the side of an
operative Scalia I am on the side of
Leone huge I am on the side of so many
of my dead very often and sometimes
living Russian friends
I'm on the side to believe me the big
disagreement about be between us and we
are we are advancing to the end is
the following first of all multipolar
ism is not a new thing though there has
always been multiple at the popular ISM
and before the collapse of Soviet Union
there was a big multilateralism between
America Russia China
Sasa is not such a new thing number one
number two you say that everyone should
respect the other one and not interfere
in the process of the other civilization
if you look honestly at the situation of
today the one who interferes the one who
tries really genuinely to destabilize
the other is not Trump destabilizing
Russia it is putting destabilizing
America and Europe today there is not
mister don't believe me I know that and
these are facts and they will be fact
checked you cannot find one extreme
rightist and neo-fascist party in Europe
which is not at least blessed and at
best
financed by Russia you cannot find one
crisis in Europe which is not encouraged
by Russia you cannot count the number in
2014 and 15 of violation of the aryan
space of Poland Lithuania and even
sometimes France by Russian planes you
know as I know in 2014 and 15 the little
declaration of Putin who is a good chess
player saying that one should revise the
legality oppa song comes out just by
passing the legality of the process of
Independence of the Baltic states
another sentence saying that from Russia
- Moscow it will take two hours and so
on so today the real imperialism the
real one who is interfering
and suing some disorder envy and an
intervening in the affairs of the other
one
alas is poutine and I'm not speaking I
should speak of America where it is now
proved that there has been a huge crude
and evident intervention in the
electoral process of the last election
and last remark Syria Libya and so this
is these are not civil civil wars again
civil war is a false concept and you are
too wise to make this mistake it is war
against civilians Syria Libya other
places it is war of a state of an army
it was in Libya and it is still in Syria
war against civilians what is true is
that you have people in the West like me
and in Russia also and in Ukraine who
took part for the civilians in Libya in
order to prevent the blood blood bath in
order to prevent what happens to the in
Syria which is four hundred thousand
dead three million displaced people in
Swat that is true but it has nothing to
do it cannot be compared to what a big
state Russia does with its big planes
with the Gaza of Bashar al-assad which
is to feed the war of aggression of
Abuja Bashar al-assad who does not care
about our discussion about civilizations
bridges blocks and sod who is just an
executioner supported today by your
president so I think that so many
exaggerations and rhetoric figure that
I'm not inclined to total to answer not
because I have no answer for example
about intervention
Oh on one side it was proof that there
was no intervention in favor of Trump
and there was interventional favor
Hillary of some Russian oligarchs so the
same for finance Monteux of far-right
movement and Europe there are many
rumors male there are many publications
there many rhetoric sore intervention of
Russia most absurd from all of them in
the Catalonia crisis but no proofs but
nevertheless what is interesting we are
uncertain I don't like to speak about
the facts now about the facts because
the the I consider the I want to speak
about what if not the facts facts
something that was done the fat sir a
Latin term that was deeds that was
construction in the man informational
age we are dealing with informational
facts so who controls the media as the
bore G the board has said control the
facts so if we don't want Whittle
readers and journalists mostly who
control the media readers and
journalists a little tycoons but a lot
readers and jonatha self-control they
aren't for us of media's the maggots in
the West this is one of the advantages
of the West it is a kind of human we
have a discussion in France today about
low mood which is the biggest newspaper
you know and there is a project of the
owners of remote to bring their shares
to a Foundation which will belong to
public interests solo mode will belong
this is the good of westernization will
belong to with readers and to its
journalists they're not they are
speaking not about the owner that we are
speaking about epistemology and the
Foucault Michele Foucault concept who
control epistemology the mass media for
example rigidly bruh has said being the
adviser of meat Iran he could not
achieve no plan with a support of
president because of some resistance
going from nowhere so there are some
epistemological center of control there
are no
owner of media interesting that this is
as epistemological struggle so one we
have one created system effect or choose
in fact biased fact and explained in a
biased way and when Russia tried to do
the same to create our mass media Russia
today Sputnik
we are blamed to have the the fake news
to say the truth we both reducing three
wise I tell you what it or a big the big
difference is that when Russia today is
invented it is invented by verticality
democracy vertical as you say in
yourself it is it is it is founded by
Putin when you have a conflict of
interpretation in the West between
Lamond
and Ophelia all between the New York
Times and the Ryan Science Monitor or
whatever it is a fight between
professionals individuals it is a
sincere attempt to find the truth it is
not a propaganda media coming from the
sky of power and this again is an
advantage West because what is true my
dear what is true is that we are out of
the age where truth comes from from the
sky like in blood Plateau
I want us to be searched and it has to
be searched with sincerity and
genuineness for that we don't need the
intervention of the state we don't need
the trolls manipulated by the Kremlin or
by a white house identity we need again
some readers some journalists civil
society all animated by a sincere and
authentic will for truth to speak like a
direct nature
this image is so beautiful that come on
come on that to Russia what is one of
the beauties that democracy can offer to
and when you embrace it it will not be
Western it will be a common good and it
will be Russian to Bush when Bush was in
Moscow and the moment of invasion of the
United States in Iraq he had said please
keep be patient you will have democracy
as well as in Iraq a Putin has said
thank you very much we will find the
other way to the potato build our
society I think that the picture we've
made is correct but that has nothing to
do with modern Western society where is
purely totalitarian way to this disc of
the fact description not in the favor of
small group of holder of one mass media
or other but a political elite rules and
they are in that sense a kind of
platonist Payton de truth from their
liberal ideology that is something
platonic as well and the people are in
the revolt against that in a different
country but as well in the West I think
the wave of populism it is precisely the
refusal of the European people not
right-wing or left-wing refusal normal
normal middle middle European citizens
that is refuse of this absolutely
abstract agenda of liberal elites so I
think that is not about state now we are
speaking about political elites ok there
is this you are good observer this
happens in the West but more generally
there is a big fight all over the world
between liberal values and the liberal
values this fight crosses our countries
- you have some liberal
in Russia and we have some liberals in
Europe and what is true is that
liberalism faces the same sort of crisis
of credibility and maybe of self
credibility as it faced in the thirties
or at the very beginning of the 20th
century but in this file mr. Dougan I
checked today we are at the end of this
debate that we will be on the two sides
of the barricade because I will for me a
free press is not totally terrorism the
cult of the respect of liberal ideas and
of freedom is not another liberalism
secularism rights of women cannot be
placed as you did at the beginning of
our encounter at the same level than
fascism and communism there is today a
real clash of civilization but not the
one you are quoting in your books
between the North and the east and the
West and the thous and all of that there
is a clash of civilization all over the
planet between those believe in human
rights in Liberty in the right for a
body not to be tortured and mottled and
those who are happy with a liberalism
and revival of authority' resume and
slavery and this is what is what makes
the difference between you between you
and me I'm sorry to objected to there
again
[Applause]